Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J'ai compris.
J’ai compris qu’il fallait 92 secondes
au patient pour raconter son histoire
s’il n’est pas interrompu.
Je n’ai qu’une chance,
en tant que thérapeute,
de faire une bonne première impression.
Ce serait dommage de la manquer, de
ne pas prendre ce temps d’écoute initial,
ô combien important pour la suite,
qui nous permettra d’établir
une alliance thérapeutique de qualité.
Quand, il y a 25 ans, je me suis
retrouvé à l’école de kiné,
j’étais partagé :
d’un côté très fier d’avoir
réussi un concours exigeant,
mais de l’autre un peu interrogatif
sur une profession que j’avais choisie,
mais sans vraiment la connaître.
En fait, pour tout vous dire, après le
bac, je voulais plutôt faire dentaire.
Ayant échoué au concours,
il a bien fallu se réorienter.
Alors je me suis dit :
« Pourquoi pas kiné ? »
Ça reste dans le médical,
et il y avait cet aspect technique
qui au départ m’intéressait.
Sauf que cela n'est pas si simple.
Il ne suffit pas d'appliquer une technique
pour obtenir un résultat.
Alors j'ai continué à me former.
J’ai par exemple pu participer aux
formations des meilleurs experts,
qu’ils soient français, anglais,
mais aussi canadiens, australiens
et même néo-zélandais.
Tout cela, je vous rassure, sans avoir
forcément à parcourir le monde,
ce qui était bien préférable
pour ma vie de famille.
Je vais sûrement vous surprendre :
Les formations qui ont eu
le plus d’impact sur moi,
ce ne sont pas celles
qui parlent de nouvelles méthodes
ou de nouveaux appareils pour soigner,
mais bien celles qui parlent
de la relation thérapeutique
et de la communication avec le patient.
Le pouvoir des mots est juste incroyable.
Il suffit parfois de regarder
et d’expliquer ce qui se passe
en termes compréhensibles
pour voir le regard du patient changer.
Et il change réellement,
comme si nous venions de lui offrir
une clé de décryptage d’une situation qui
lui pesait depuis trop longtemps déjà.
J’ai vraiment commencé
à apprécier mon métier
à partir du moment où j’ai pris ce temps
nécessaire pour écouter mon patient,
pour le conseiller et pour établir
avec lui son plan de traitement.
Et en même temps,
je suis parfois comme découragé
de voir tous ces patients enfermés dans le
cercle vicieux de la douleur chronique,
avec un système de soins totalement
dépassé par ces problèmes.
J’aimerais vous parler de la maladie
qui génère le plus de handicaps
chez nous en Europe.
L’OMS a établi un classement sur
le fardeau mondial des maladies
et la lombalgie est loin
devant toutes les autres.
Qui parmi vous a déjà eu mal au dos ?
Levez la main pour voir.
Ah oui, quand même.
Il existe bien sûr plusieurs
types de mal de dos.
Celui qui vous tiraille
de temps en temps le matin,
celui que vous ressentez suite
à une position assise prolongée
ou bien debout à piétiner,
ou encore celle que vous aurez suite
à une activité sûrement exagérée.
Je vous rassure, cette forme de lombalgie
est très fréquente, presque banale,
et se guérit le plus souvent spontanément,
et en moins de six semaines.
On sait que presque 90% de la population
aura au moins une fois,
et souvent plus, mal au dos dans sa vie.
Il y a cette autre forme,
celle qui ne vous quitte jamais,
celle qui vous empêche de travailler,
de faire du sport,
de voir vos amis, de rigoler,
celle qui vous empêche de vivre,
tout simplement.
Cette forme, c’est la lombalgie chronique
et elle touche 6% de la population,
ce qui est énorme.
Et cela constitue un véritable
enjeu de santé publique.
La science sur le sujet des lombalgies
évolue sans cesse.
Nous savons aujourd’hui qu’il est
indispensable d’intégrer le psycho-social
et pas uniquement se concentrer
sur le biomédical,
aussi bien pour l’expliquer,
la prévenir et aussi la traiter.
En réfléchissant
sur un mode bio-psycho-social,
nous ne cherchons plus une cause unique.
Prenez, si vous voulez bien,
une image, un vase,
un vase que l’on remplirait
de liquides tous différents
qui feraient progresser le niveau.
Ces liquides, ça pourrait être
des contraintes physiques
avec vos sacs de courses que vous avez
péniblement montés sur trois étages.
Ou encore des contraintes professionnelles
avec votre collègue
qui, encore une fois,
n’aura pas rendu ses papiers à temps.
Mais ça peut être aussi la fatigue
que vous accumulez jour après jour,
liée au manque de sommeil.
Ce vase qui se remplit
avec des éléments tous différents,
à la fois bio, psycho et social,
eh bien, il peut arriver qu’il déborde.
Il ne suffit d'ailleurs que d'une
goutte pour le faire déborder.
Cette goutte, ce peut être ce papier
que vous venez de ramasser.
Ou bien ce faux mouvement
qui vous aurait surpris.
Mais ça peut être également cette mauvaise
nouvelle que vous venez d’entendre.
Ce vase qui déborde,
c’est votre mal de dos,
et dans sa forme chronique,
il est en permanence rempli d’eau.
Si on cherche à prévenir ce problème,
il faudra d’une part considérer
le problème dans sa globalité
et également disposer d’outils
pour régulièrement vider votre vase.
« Le bon traitement, c’est le mouvement. »
Vous connaissez cet adage ?
Nous savons que l’activité physique
est un traitement de choix
qui permet de réduire à peu près
de 50% le risque de récidive.
Ces mots distillés autour
d’une communication multicanale
ont été assez bien retenus par
la population - vous vous en rappelez.
Par contre, il suffit aussi
de se montrer patient,
parce que les changements s’effectuaient
sur des temps longs et, dans certains cas,
certaines idées anciennes persistent
et peuvent favoriser
le passage à la chronicité.
Alors,
si tous ces éléments constituent
la prise en charge idéale de la lombalgie,
ne pourrions-nous pas tous ensemble
les diffuser plus largement
avant qu’elle ne devienne chronique ?
Sur cette planète rêvée
qu’est la prévention,
les professionnels de santé
recevraient leurs patients
pour qu’ils restent en bonne santé.
J’espère vraiment que
cela ne soit pas qu’un rêve,
que la prévention devienne la norme
et que l’on puisse enfin
prévenir plutôt que guérir.
Nous connaissons assez peu
notre corps et comment il bouge.
En prévention, nous proposerions
pour les jeunes et les moins jeunes
de découvrir et de comprendre notre corps.
Ce sont des prérequis indispensables
pour agir et devenir
acteur de notre santé.
Être acteur de sa santé
ne se résume pas uniquement
à être observant d’une liste d’exercices
qu’on nous aurait prescrits,
il s’agit également de prendre ses
responsabilités quant aux choix possibles
et, dans certains cas,
d’accepter un diagnostic
tout en cherchant à travailler
et à en modifier le pronostic.
Il n’existe pas de programme universel,
ce serait trop simple.
[Il s’agit] plutôt de fournir des clés de
compréhension accessibles et des outils
pour permettre à chacun d’agir
en fonction de ses besoins.
Une prévention individualisée
et non dogmatique en quelque sorte.
Les professionnels de santé
utilisent un langage technique
que vous ne comprenez pas forcément.
Et vous, vous ressentez votre corps.
Chacun doit vraiment
apprendre l’un de l’autre.
Et rappelez-vous,
c’est vous qui détenez l’information.
Certains auteurs ont proposé un lexique
pour le transformer ce discours,
ce jargon médical,
en termes positifs et compréhensibles.
Un lumbago, par exemple, n’est simplement
qu’un mal de dos qui vient d’arriver -
un mot en latin qui ne décrit
que la situation.
Si nous pouvions observer chacun
d’entre vous aux rayons X,
nous découvririons des dégénérescences
discales chez bon nombre d’entre vous,
que vous souffriez ou non de votre dos.
Si on devait utiliser notre lexique,
nous pourrions lire sur le compte-rendu
que la radio montre des signes
d’usure liés à l’âge,
ce qui, vous me l’accorderez,
est nettement plus rassurant.
C’est un peu comme dire
qu’il y a des cheveux blancs.
Ces signes étaient là avant,
ils le seront sans doute après.
Les déformations du dos comme
les scolioses méritent d’être suivis.
Pour autant, elles ne
s’accompagnent pas forcément
de douleur ni de limitation d’activité.
Savez-vous par exemple que Usain Bolt,
l’incroyable sprinter jamaïcain,
détenteur en 9s58 du record du 100 m,
est lui aussi porteur
d’une magnifique scoliose ?
Méfiez-vous également de tous ces bons
conseils que votre famille et vos amis
vous prodigueront à la moindre occasion.
Tout le monde a son idée sur la question.
De même, Internet est très utile
pour préparer une présentation,
mais nettement moins pour se rassurer
quand on a mal au dos.
Ne cherchez pas les méthodes miracles,
il n'en existe pas.
Croyez bien que si cela existait, nous
n’entendrions plus parler de mal de dos.
Le mal de dos est très fréquent,
touche presque tout le monde
et guérit en général rapidement
et souvent sans traitement particulier.
Parfois, il est nécessaire de prendre
du recul sur la situation
et se projeter dans l'après.
Même si sur le moment, vous ne voyez pas
du tout comment vous allez vous en sortir,
restez confiant.
De façon inconsciente,
nous avons l’habitude de nous rappeler
toutes les fois où ça s’est mal passé.
Et si cette fois,
nous faisions le contraire ?
Rappelez-vous ce mal de dos,
certes douloureux,
qui s’est résolu
en seulement quelques jours.
Ne vous êtes-vous jamais dit :
« J’en ai plein le dos » ?
La persistance d’une douleur et même dans
certains cas, son déclenchement,
peut être en lien avec des facteurs
liés à vous ou aux autres.
En quelque sorte, rappelez-vous
le modèle bio-psycho-social.
La douleur,
existe vraiment, elle n’est pas
le fruit de votre imagination,
mais de nombreux facteurs
vont l’influencer et la moduler.
Par contre,
la douleur ne signifie pas forcément
que quelque chose est abîmé
ou cassé dans votre corps.
Le corps, lui, il est solide.
Il a été conçu pour bouger,
porter des charges, faire du sport.
Il se nourrit de toutes ces actions
et les limiter le fragilise.
Aussi, la posture idéale n’existe pas.
Elle n'existe pas.
Le corps n'a pas été conçu
pour rester statique.
Dans l’inconfort, notre corps réagit
et nous nous surprenons
à réaliser certains mouvements.
En bon héros de votre dos,
identifiez-les et en prévention,
utilisons-les avant d’en avoir besoin,
cela marchera encore mieux.
D’ailleurs, vous êtes assis sur vos sièges
depuis bien trop longtemps
et je pense que le moment est venu pour
vous de vous lever, si vous voulez bien.
Souvent,
après être resté longtemps assis,
moi, j’utilise ce mouvement-là.
J’emmène le dos vers l’arrière.
Je vous propose de le tester ensemble,
d’abord tout doucement,
pour initier le corps à ce nouveau
mouvement, puis de plus en plus loin.
Bien sûr, pour ceux qui pour qui ce
serait douloureux, ne le faites pas.
Je ne veux pas avoir de problèmes.
(Rires)
On va faire ça 4 ou 5 fois
gentiment, de plus en plus loin.
Et votre corps vous dira assez
rapidement ce qu'il en pense.
J'ai un autre mouvement à vous proposer.
Celui-là, je suis sûr
que vous le connaissez déjà.
Il y a une règle :
mettez-vous d’accord avec le voisin
pour que chacun tourne dans le même sens.
Ce mouvement, c'est la danse du ventre.
Vous allez commencer
par desserrer un frein à main :
vous relâchez l’ensemble des muscles
et partez dans un mouvement circulaire,
d’abord dans un sens,
en élargissant le cercle,
puis dans l’autre sens.
Ça va ?
C’est un mouvement
que je recommande le matin
pour initier le corps à un nouveau
mouvement, pour le réveiller.
Et ne me dites pas que cela prend
du temps, cela ne prend pas de temps,
il suffit juste d’y penser.
Si vous voulez bien vous rasseoir.
(Rit)
Le temps est compté, je suis désolé.
Les recommandations de l’OMS
concernant l’activité physique
sont claires et sans ambiguïté.
Nous ne bougeons pas assez et cela a une
répercussion sur notre qualité de vie
et sur la survenue des maladies.
C’est dommage parce que l’activité
physique est bonne pour tout :
pour le corps, le cœur et aussi l'esprit.
Un peu comme un médicament
avec tous les effets positifs
mais sans les effets indésirables.
Vous allez me demander :
« Quelle activité choisir ? »
Eh bien, un scoop : la meilleure activité
sera celle que vous ferez.
C’est vrai.
(Rit)
(Applaudissements)
Toutes les activités sont bonnes,
toutes les activités physiques comptent.
Le sport, mais aussi
des activités du quotidien :
marcher régulièrement, prendre
les escaliers plutôt que les ascenseurs
ou bien aller travailler à vélo
ou je ne sais quoi.
Les meilleurs conseils seront
d’être régulier, progressif,
et surtout de prendre du plaisir.
Par progressivité, nous pensons d’une
part à échauffer notre corps,
comme nous l’avons vu, que ce soit dans
une activité de loisir, de sport,
mais aussi au travail, et aussi
en quantifiant notre activité,
en ajoutant des charges
de façon progressive
pour le rendre robuste et tolérant.
Car contrairement aux machines,
notre corps s’adapte,
à condition de ne pas y aller,
ni trop vite, ni trop fort.
Allez-y par petits pas.
Alors, écoutez votre corps et bougez.
Vous pouvez vraiment être
les héros de votre dos.
J’aimerais vous donner
et vous confier quatre clés.
D’une part, soyez curieux
pour découvrir votre corps.
Concentrez-vous sur vos solutions, les
éléments sur lesquels vous pouvez agir.
Et rappelez-vous, les solutions les plus
simples sont souvent les meilleures.
Le principe Kiss -
Keep it simple and stupid.
Faites de l’activité -
c’est un bon moyen de vider votre vase -
restez confiant et pensez positif.
Je ne résiste pas à l’envie
de vous confier un dernier conseil.
De nombreux coaches recommandent
l’utilisation des power postures
pour améliorer la confiance en soi.
J’aimerais tester avec vous et je vais
encore vous demander de vous lever.
de tester la posture Wonderwoman
qui, on le sait moins,
est un puissant antidote
contre la posture avachie.
Alors, jambes écartées, les pieds bien
ancrés dans le sol, mains sur les hanches,
vous allez, en respirant,
emmener les coudes vers l’arrière
en prenant une grande respiration.
(Expire)
Et nous allons réaliser ça trois fois.
(Inspire)
Deux.
(Expire)
(Inspire)
Et trois.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)